le moment où tu es monté pour la
première fois sur ton harley à toi tu as
ressenti quoi je demandais depuis la
première harley en 1903 les relations
entre la moto et le biker entêté
fusionnelle alors n'allez pas dire que
c'est une banale motocyclette
déjà dans les années 70 la distinction
était fait
il passe la tête haute sur leurs motos
harnaché comme un arbre de noël
ils ne sont pas considérés comme de
vrais motards n'ont eux ce sont des
bikers ils font partie d'une communauté
ils se veulent rebelles customise leur
bécane pour en faire un objet unique
exemple avec le chanteur christophe
gmail à celle là celle flic a bien
amérique
j'aimais le gyrophare enfin dire j'ai un
peu personnalisés depuis toujours les
fans de harley sont accusés d'être des
frimeurs mais c'est assumer ça c'est une
moto de frime
il ya eus je l'achète ce qui me plaît
c'est quand je vois une harley je
regarde si elle m'épate donc aux primes
c'est qu'on existe la prime
l'amour du rêve américain la liberté de
rouler c'est bien joli mais dans les
années 80 harley davidson est au bord de
la faillite
alors les dirigeants ont une idée
renforcer les liens sociaux autour de la
marque marketing communautaire
une première pour garder les moteurs
l'entousiasme qu'il porte pour la vie
dont les amis et pour le produit nous
avons créé en 1983 le groupe d'honneur
les davidson ce club est parti de zéro
et nous en sommes à 95 milles mans et ça
fonctionne dès l'achat d'une harley le
nouvel adepte entre dans le club et est
invité à participer à des sorties
organisées par la marque
ce que j'aime c'est le plaisir de rouler
en bande sans faire les fous parce que
nous ne voulons pas très vite
bien loin de l'équipée sauvage la
famille des bikers et légèrement
bourgeoise et les cadres sup ont
remplacé les gangs
mais cet esprit communautaire est encore
bien présent vingt ans après le
lancement du club
on a tout dit sur la légendaire harlem
et les véritables passionnés sont
intarissables au sein du club on peut
enfin se réunir et par les bécanes
aujourd'hui le club officiel
harley-davidson compte près d'un million
d'adhérents à travers le monde
mais la marque en veut toujours plus et
se tournent maintenant vers les femmes
qu'elle veut fédérer en communauté de
bikeuse
[Musique]